J'ai senti un morceau de moi disparaître un morceau
qui n'est jamais revenu en d'autres termes je
n'allais pas bien et je ne vais PAS bien
[Musique]
mon expérience de la violence domestique était-
ce un abus mental, physique et sexuel toxique
qui a commencé lentement mais s'est intensifié
avec le temps, y compris  menaces contre ma
vie
éclairage au gaz sévère et lavage de cerveau se
réveiller avec l'homme qui prétendait m'aimer
violer ce qu'il croyait être mon
corps inconscient dans le pire des
rituels malades de me lier par les mains et
les pieds pour être mentalement et physiquement
torturé jusqu'à ce que  mon agresseur a senti que j'avais
prouvé mon amour pour eux en ce moment
alors que j'étais attaché à être battu et à me
faire dire des choses indescriptibles, j'avais vraiment
l'impression que je pouvais mourir non seulement parce que
mon agresseur m'a dit que je pouvais te tuer
maintenant
mais parce que dans  à ce moment-là, j'ai eu l'impression de
quitter mon corps et j'avais trop peur de courir, il me
trouverait, je me suis figé et c'était comme
si je pouvais me voir de l'extérieur
et pour la première fois depuis des mois, j'ai ressenti
quelque chose de
honte et de désespoir  aucune idée de
quoi faire pour changer ma situation alors je suis
devenu engourdi et bientôt je ne pouvais plus
rien ressentir je n'étais pas vivant mon estime de soi
et mon esprit étaient brisés j'étais profondément
terrifié et cette peur m'habite à
ce jour ce qui me rend  plus blessée et
plus en colère que le viol et
les abus eux-mêmes, c'est cette partie de moi qui
a été volée qui a changé le cours de
ma vie à cause de cet abus, ma
personne déjà sans âme quand j'ai été poussée sur
le sol d'un placard de stockage verrouillé par
un autre agresseur  après des heures dans un bar, mon
corps savait instinctivement quoi faire
disparaître
kono le faire disparaître être abusé et
violé auparavant m'a permis
d'être à nouveau violée plus facilement et pas l'
inverse et pas un jour ne passe sans que je
n'entende pas le  mots que cet homme m'a chuchotés
à l'oreille encore et encore tu vas
bien aller tu vas aller tu vas
aller et puis ma petite voix
a chanté en retour non non non non non non non
non jusqu'à ce qu'elle s'estompe en rien
et  Je me souviens de la sensation de
m'arrêter ou de geler et de
subir un choc total et je ne pouvais même pas émettre un son J'ai
senti un morceau de moi disparaître un morceau
qui n'est jamais revenu en d'autres termes je
n'allais pas bien
et je ne vais PAS bien même si  ces
expériences se sont produites il y a dix ans. Je
lutte toujours avec les conséquences. Ma
relation souffre. Mes partenaires souffrent. Ma
santé mentale et physique souffre
sept ans après mes viols.
condition Je
pensais simplement que je devenais fou J'ai
lutté contre la dépression la dépendance
l'agoraphobie les terreurs nocturnes tant de fois qu'un de
mes partenaires endormis est réveillé par
son amour en hurlant dans la nuit et à bout de
souffle et une mare de sueur
après avoir eu une sorte de rêve vif de
mon agresseur les entend dire mon nom si
fort dans mon oreille la sensation de
paralysie revient quand il y a un
bruit fort et que je suis seul à la maison convaincu que
quelqu'un vient me faire du mal je reste
éveillé toute la nuit tenant une batte de baseball
qui a commencé à remplacer mon désarroi  et
partenaires absents alors que la confiance et le toucher
devenaient de plus en plus difficiles J'ai
lutté contre l'automutilation au point de
deux tentatives de suicide qui m'ont amené dans
un hôpital psychiatrique pendant une courte
période et ce fut cependant un
tournant dans ma vie quand j'ai commencé
je cherche une aide professionnelle pour faire face à
mon traumatisme et à mon stress mental mais d'autres
n'ont pas cette chance et à cause de ce
viol c'est souvent plus que quelques minutes de
traumatisme mais une mort lente et je voudrais
dire à mes agresseurs que je ne déteste pas
toi je suis désolé pour toi je ne suis pas là pour te faire
honte je veux te comprendre et je
veux que tu me comprennes mais tu dois
d'abord écouter et cela me fait penser
à mon fils et au monde dans lequel il sera
élevé et  le jour où je devrai
lui expliquer ce que signifie le viol et pourquoi
c'est arrivé à sa mère, nous devons
adopter la déclaration des droits des victimes d'agression sexuelle
dans les 50 États, nous l'avons fait
un neuf jusqu'à présent et c'est notre travail de
s'assurer  que les survivants des 41 autres
sont traités avec la même humanité et
dignité et cela s'appelle le progrès et
ça commence ici merci